На ранок після чергового нічного обстрілу Миколаїв повертається до життя.
Вода взагалі дуже відволікає від усього.
І от тому, я надіюся, що сьогодні вони знову прийдуть,
і сьогодні вони зможуть відволіктись.
Під акомпанемент сирен і вибухів у цих стінах твориться майбутнє українського спорту.
Молодець! Це вже набагато краще. Молодець! Змучився?
Майбутніх чемпіонів і чемпіонок готує паралімпієць Андрій Козленко.
Спортсмен радий повернутися до звичних тренувань в Миколаєві,
які довелося скасувати майже на рік через постійні обстріли.
У перші дні після нападу Росії на Україну Андрій Козленко став волонтером.
Тренування зупинилися, все зупинилося. І перші 2-3 дні, як і кожен українець,
як і кожна людина, яка в нас живе, було нерозуміння, що робити далі.
У мене немає змоги піти на фронт, тому що… через інвалідність.
Я патріот своєї країни, свого міста, і я буду робити все, щоб ми перемогли, що від мене потрібно.
Разом із товаришами Андрій створив волонтерський центр, який опікувався потребами жителів Миколаєва.
У перші місяці роботи команда зосередилася на гуманітарній допомозі.
Андрій взявся за напрям забезпечення ліками.
Нам прийшов запит. Тоді дуже було важко дістати ліки.
І оскільки я паралімпієць, я зміг виїхати і дістати.
Багато я привіз ліків, дуже багато.
І ми змогли допомогти тоді людям, тому що в аптеках все змітали, нічого не було.
Це були препарати Л-Тироксин, Еутирокс, що було важко дістати.
А в Болгарії вони були навіть дешевші, ніж у нас.
Кожен обстріл Миколаєва ставив нові завдання перед командою волонтерів.
Потреби у ліках стрімко зростали.
У нас був обстріл, і хлопчик онкохворий потрапив під обстріл. Потрібні були ліки.
Сума була 20 тисяч, десь плюс 22, ось так. І ми за 12 годин зібрали цю суму.
Згодом Андрій почав допомагати українським військовим. Цим займається й дотепер.
Щоправда, часу на волонтерство нині вже менше,
адже своїх учнів Андрій готує до загальноукраїнських і європейських змагань.
Я дуже хочу, щоб наші діти через такого підступного ворога не страждали.
Вони не заслуговують цього, щоб у 6-7 років, у 3 місяці, до 15 років, це так не важливо, щоб вони так страждали.
Тому мені важливо було продовжити роботу, свою роботу.
Спорт і волонтерство тепер невіддільні складові життя й паралімпійця Олега Науменка.
Волонтерство для фехтувальника почалося з дзвінка давнього друга.
Він дзвонить і каже, що у них з'явився 3D-принтер.
І вони розробили ці перископи. Вони самі це все створили, дизайн, все, що могли, це вони повністю все зробили.
І їм потрібні були кошти, тому що перші перископи передали своїм друзям із ЗСУ.
Вони були дуже високо оцінені, але це така річ, це як розхідник, і тому треба їх було багато.
Так спортсмен почав разом із друзями займатися виготовленням перископів.
Їх друкують на 3D-принтерах.
Перископ допомагає проглядати позиції військових РФ, не виходячи з укриття.
Це дає можливість зберегти життя українських військових.
Від початку вторгнення миколаївським волонтерам вдалося надрукувати близько тисячі перескопів.
Нині Олег Науменко продовжує займатися волонтерством і…  фехтуванням.
Деякий час ми тренувалися, потім був приліт поруч, як ви бачите, тут зараз всі вікна позакривані.
Ми коли прийшли, то тут всередині все було в уламках.
Ми поприбирали, потім почали тренуватися, як могли.
Але тренуватися в таких умовах дуже важко.
Саме тому паралімпійська збірна України з фехтування на візках виїхала до Німеччини.
Проте Олег вирішив не залишати Миколаїв.
Лише час від часу він виїжджає за кордон на тренування і змагання,
але щоразу повертається додому.
Ти відчуваєш, що ти зможеш чимось допомогти, ти тут потрібний. Це перше.
Інше, я не знаю, чи можна так казати або ні, але ти відчуваєш,
що зараз в Україні твориться така історія, ти хочеш брати в цьому участь.
Нині фехтувальник готується до етапу Кубка світу.
На змаганнях у Варшаві Олег прагне зайняти призові місця, щоби вкотре нагадати світові про Україну.
Я взагалі більшість нагород отримав за цей рік, ніж за ті всі разом взяті, що було до цього.
Чому так - я не знаю. Ну, якщо чесно так, якщо відверто сказати,
то, мабуть, раніше ти фехтував для себе, а зараз ти фехтуєш…
Всім зрозуміло, для чого ти фехтуєш. І це дуже мотивує,
це дуже надихає.